s'est retrouvé dans une immense caverne
qui était rempli d'extraterrestres des
grands gris comme on les appelle castex
distinctivement et l'a sorti son
pistolet c'est un petit modèle et il a
tiré
schnyder prétend que la stratégie fera
passer la main au dessus de sa poitrine
était qu un rayon laser en des sorties à
la halle au rayon a brûlé la paume de sa
main et sa poitrine a été ouverte ont de
leur art ne ressemblait pas à des
pistolets sa transpercé ma peau est
ouvert ma cage thoracique est tombé en
amour avec lui croyez-moi fond le coeur
bien accroché
alors la question la question reste
posée jean votre bourré est-ce que vous
non les écrins thérèse sont ils déjà
parmi nous parce que moi je suis comme
ça j'ai la trouille
alors la nasa a répondu à votre question
elle a dit quoi il y a quatre ans la
nasa fin communiqué qui est passée
inaperçue c'est tous mes confrères qui
aurait dû quand même mettre en valeur en
dix ans nous venons d'étudier avec
l'intelligence artificielle
tous les clichés qui viennent d'être
pris par les satellites dans lesquels il
y à des télescopes rails et nous
estimons écoutez bien le nombre nous
estimons nous la nasa à 60 milliards
je rappelle qu'un milliard c'est 1000
millions merci jusqu'en cm2 donc vous
savez
nous estimons à 60 milliards le nombre
de planètes dans notre galaxie
susceptibles d'abriter la vie 60
milliards et le nombre de galaxies est
passé de 200 milliards à 2000 milliards
donc imaginez qu'on est les seuls êtres
vivants de l'hiver même si c'est
totalement absurde
alors on a notre extrait c'est le pilote
de air force one donc avec eux de barack
obama
quelle époque ah bah ya vu un devenu
regarder les images alors que le vol se
déroule paisiblement ondes ou dans eager
voit soudain apparaître quelque chose
qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu de sa vie et
je lève les yeux et là incroyable je
vois une gigantesque boule de feu
au dessus des nuages
c'était énorme tas occupé presque tout
le ciel ça a duré environ une minute et
la boule a totalement disparu derrière
mariage et là des éclairs ont jailli des
nuages s'étaient sidérant
vous pensez que c'était un ovni aucun
doute alors jacques vous vous avez
rencontré à un ovni en avion tout à fait
et d'ailleurs l'image du collimateur que
vous faisiez la truite à l'heure c'est
un chasseur qui fait une poursuite sur
un 2 volants non identifiés et moi
sommes arrivés nous étions deux mirage
le pote de mirage iii c'était la guerre
froide pour on est tous les matins on
avait des cours pour savoir ce qui se
trame à aller un peu en l'air si c'était
à vue américain des avions russes etc et
on est en train de faire un entraînement
de rassemblement de rassemblement de
nuit et c'est ce que j'ai pris d'amour
pour à l'avion vers l'avion de ligne est
apparue n'ont pas de contact radar avec
le sol donc plus ça va aller je suis la
police du ciel puisque c'est notre rôle
de voir un peu ce qui sera balai dans le
ciel de france et qui n'était pas
identifié
et au moment où d'approché à une
distance qu'il devait être pour lui il
va lui ou ce qu'il y avait dedans ça
zones de vulnérabilité ça nous
paraissait aller vitesse des terres
alors on a on a un autre témoignage
c'était un pilote comme vous qui lui
carrément a eu un contact direct avec
avec canadiens regardent fort stone est
convoqué pour communiquer avec un
extraterrestre arrêté par l'armée
américaine je n'oublierai jamais ce
qu'il m'a dit j'ai peur à ce moment là
je lui dis est ce que ça vous aiderait
si je voulais sortir est née sept pays
l'a dit une fois que je serai sorti plus
personne n'aura souffrir de crin j'ai
dit le colonel
il veut nous montrer quelque chose à moi
et à personne d'autre
les autres peuvent sortir du bâtiment
sinon ils seront en danger
toné l'extraterrestre sortent du
bâtiment et parviennent à atteindre la
clôture sans être vue par les gardes
j'ai coupé le grillage ajoutant qu'il
était assez de place on s'en tire quand
il est sorti une lumière est apparu
qu'il est descendu puis à les remonter
et il avait disparu
la question c'est est-ce qu'ils sont
parmi nous parce que là quand on voit ça
bon ça me paraît un peu paraître un peu
farfelu via il ya ceux qui me croient
qu'il est papa est la question
c'est à quoi je peux reconnaître un
écrin terrestre c'est extrêmement simple
bah là non c'est tellement simple vous
allez voir en france il ya des
catholiques des protestants des juifs et
des musulmans
jusque là je vous suis alors il suffit
de lire la bible au de lire le coran
vous prenez le coran la sera de 53
l'étoile que dit le droit de 53 ne sais
pas eh ben elle dit c'est mahomet qui
parle mahomet est mort le 6 juin 632 il
n'a pas écrit le coran mais on a écrit
le coran à partir de ce qu'il a dit un
petit peu après il dit et voici que je
vois des cendres la lune à l'intérieur
de la lune il ya quelqu'un qui me parle
c'est l'archange et jabil archange
gabriel et je vois la lune écoutez bien
c'est dans le coran à moins de deux
portes et dark une portée d'arc c'est 50
mètres et même plus près c'est à dire
qu'ils voient la lune avait quelqu'un à
l'intérieur qui lui parle à moins de 100
mètres mais ressemble à bien la bible
qu'elle versait et dans la bible c'est
exactement la même chose dhr dans
l'abîmé ronald reagan avait volé plus
pour les juifs hurlent de terreur je
veux savoir à quoi il ressemble parce
que riche il est inquiet
moi à vous à moi n'importe lequel
d'entre nous et je vais vous expliquer
de son corps 20 secondes parce que vous
avez plus de temps aux bogdanov
[Applaudissements]
j'entends dire qu'on sait que
l'artistique montrer qu'on est les seuls
dans l'univers ça paraît improbable
on a un autre extrait regardez c'est le
plus plu c'est une spéciale aux
américaines
bon bah est le seul avec lui nismo faire
sans revenir
c'est une sorte de rôle mais qu il y en
a toute notre regard sur les navigateurs
de vols prennent aux dieux ils vont
contre le vent besoin est de 220
km/heure toi tu regardes tu as un mec
les affaires des bleus
parce que là on tient une mouche qui
collait sur de la chaudière
non c'est pas c'est pas une mouche c'est
ce sont deux chasseurs f 16
je le raconte dans notre dernier livre
qui s'appelle contact cosmique que j'ai
l'âme trédaniel que j'ai là c'est un
témoignage extraordinairement précis qui
a été reconnus comme authentiques par le
pentagone
il ya quelques semaines seulement il a
été validé sa a été tourné en 2004 par
des chasseurs américains f 16
et qu'est ce qu'ils voient il voit
effectivement cette chose qu'ils
poursuivent à 1800 km heure et qui les
laissent sur place puisque c'est est
capable de faire 150 km en 2 secondes
j'étais petit extrait on jeudi dans des
formats il dit à moi oui mais alors je
vous expliquais jours à l'air normal 15
secondes si vous me donnez qu'un second
guerre seconde meilleure seconde dans la
bible il est écrivain commence dans la
bible il est écrit dans le pentateuque
chapitre 6 il est écrit
il est écrit les fils de dieu les fils
de dieu trouvèrent les filles de la
terre à leurs goûts sûrs commerce avec
elles et leur firent des enfants c'est à
dire qu'il ya boudent adn venue des
étoiles en chacun d'entre nous oui oui
vous me permettrez de m'adresser aux
extraterrestres non c'est vrai ceux qui
nous regardent et ceux qui nous écoutent
et parce que non mais vous pouvez rire
moi j'écris énormément et notamment ceux
qui sont en lorraine parce que la
lorraine aime les extraterrestres il y
en a beaucoup là-bas et la lorraine
fétiche avec la 9eme montrer ya beaucoup
de témoignages en lorraine
il ya eu beaucoup d'apparitions je leur
dis simplement aux extraterrestres que
nous les aimons même se hisse y en a qui
sont sceptiques qui n'y croit pas on les
aime
et quand ils viendront parce qu'ils
viendront bientôt vie qui redresse et
qui parle même à ceux qui ne les aimait
pas rassuré ses hôtes qui a fait d'elle
une rencontre donc avec l'un des freins
terrestre et qui a fait un malaise
d'avril la personne ex intéressés donc
arrivé il a craqué à l'appel un malaise
regardez et quand j'ai enfin pu sortir
du vaisseau il y avait quelque chose de
différent et je voudrais
[Musique]
stéphanie chine piper est évacuée
d'urgence mais contre toute attente elle
réapparaît quelques minutes plus tard
mais vous avez le voir lorsqu'elle va
reprendre pour la seconde fois le récit
de sa rencontre extraterrestre c'est un
peu comme si une force invisible l'en
empêchaient et donc je me suis rendu
compte que je pouvais tenir
[Musique]
leila messmer sa forme et vous vous
basez sur la bible le coran ce c'est
bien beau mais moi j'y crois à une
existence extraterrestre mais le
problème c'est que ces documents sont
décrédibilisés dès lors que vous les
représenter comme roswell avec des yeux
globuleux et ses ingénieurs rejoint donc
son secret pour toi l'existence elle
s'intéresse ne serait pas une plante un
organe totalement différent voilà ce
serait moins spectaculaire mais c'est
possible ou un présentateur de touche
pas à mon poste
pour l'instant je le sens je me sens
bien terrien mais j'aimerais bien être
un excellent concert de sam ça
m'arrangerait si vous le permettez je
trouve pour les divorces
c'est jean claude bourret ça fait des
années qui défend ses théories avec
vraiment conviction et souvent il va
subir les sarcasmes des gens qui ne le
crois pas je me demande d'où vient cette
force jean-claude parce qu'à chaque fois
tu maintiens tout ce que tu dis tu es
ferme tu écrit des bouquins je trouve ça
magnifique mais je vais vous faire une
révélation ce soir en exclusivité
mondiale allait si bien que je suis très
sérieux quand j'étais petit j'ai été
contacté on dirait pas bon
la mort est ado vous avez rencontré je
ne suis pas le seul je peux vous dire ah
oui alors là ça s'est passé comment
moins agréable ça va je n'en dirai pas
plus pour une raison extrêmement simple
c'est un peu comme un petit enfant de 5
ans qui dit maman comment on fait les
enfants le à dire bah écoute le papa il
met une petite graine dans le ventre de
la maman
il va pas lui dire ton père il avait
bondi imaginaire
c'est pareil pour vous faites le si vous
lisez contact cosmique je suis d'autant
plus à l'aise lire que je donne tout
mais droit une oeuvre c'est pas une
histoire de c'est une histoire ne
connaissant guîtres et dames et oui mais
moi je veux j'ai moi je veux comprendre
j'ai été contacté moi quand on me
contacte
c'est en haute savoie c'était à côté de
saint gervais les bains et 47 ans que je
fais des enquêtes que j'ai rencontré des
gens très hauts placés dans les services
secrets
évidemment que j'ai fait la première
interview d'un ministre d'état chargé de
la défense nationale en france on le
retrouve si vous allez sur le web ou
taper bourré galéjer à deux lots y ovni
vous trouverez la première interview que
j'ai fait du ministre de la défense qui
dit oui nous avons dans l'armée
française c'était en 1974
des centaines de cas d'observation par
des pilotes de chasse en voici un an à
mes côtés qui sont totalement crédible
il faut garder vis-à-vis ces phénomènes
une attitude d'esprit extrêmement
ouverte et chaque fois que j'ai fait une
conférence quelque part j'ai l'habitude
des rigolades de on m'a même quelquefois
fait surgir des petits bonnes âmes
déguisé en bonhomme vert tout ça n'est
pas que vous avez vu dans le ciel ou
bien sûr ils sont revenus sur terre je
ne peux pas vous en dire plus bas il
faut pas répondre à l'offre ce qui est
sûr c'est que lorsque vous dites
et apparemment il est savez ce critère
c'est vrai que quand on a demandé au
président obama
ce qu'ils pensaient de légumes d écarter
reste visiblement en amérique plus
qu'ailleurs
visiblement plus qu'ailleurs les
présidents ont été confrontés à d
aussi classé secret défense regardez sa
réponse c'est une façon de répondre ou
une mois quand même le poisson regarder
ni riz du sida
[Rires]
vous êtes quelqu'un qui a répandu c'est
le président medvedev de russie il ya un
peu plus de quatre ans une journaliste
lui pose hors antenne les 10 mai et elle
se marre parce que elle croit pas du
tout aux années il est celui qui connaît
pas le dossier dit tout ça c'est des
bêtises pour pas dire des conneries mais
ceux qui savent ce qu'ils connaissent
ceux qui travaillent sérieusement font
le tri et ils savent qu'il ya quelque
chose extrêmement solide et que dit
medvedev le président de la russie très
sérieux vous pouvez le trouver sur le
web il dit dès que nous sommes élus
présidents des grands états on est
contacté non on a la liste dans une
valise de ceux qui sont les
extraterrestres permis est ce qu'on
risque quelque chose à l'équipe et ça
fait beaucoup quand même comme avoir
malheureusement ça aurait quelque chose
la question est apparemment intelligente
ma question ça me rassure
apparemment qu'est ce qu'on risque mais
s'ils n'ont pas c'est ce qu'on explique
avec jean pierre petit doigt en contact
cosmi j'ai très bien compris
non mais je dis ça parce que c'est un
peu je suis un véhicule de la
connaissance et de la culture moi j'ai
plus rien n'est gagné
j'ai vraiment dit soixante dix huit ans
mais j'aimerais bien que des jeunes
votre l'un de vos assistants par exemple
il a été très intéressé par tout ce que
je me dis que j'ai fait un cours nous
accélérions vincent j'adore majtan et
j'adore je suis dubitatif et j'adore
donc est-ce qu'ils ont le même espace
temps que nous c'est ça la question
fondamentale est d'ordre dans ce livre
on est jean pierre petit qui est docteur
de physique et ancien directeur de
recherche du cnrs explique que nous
vivons dans deux espaces différents ce
qui explique tout le reste c'est à dire
les miracles de toutes les religions
fatima etc
c'est extrêmement ce qu'on risque est
que concrètement il ya un risque pour
nous espèce humaine voilà ça la question
et aller simple directement sien est
toujours quand on est face à l'inconnu
et là nous sommes face à l'inconnu un
risque pourquoi ils sont parmi nous et
pourquoi ils prennent pas contact avec
nous c'est la question classique
bah je vais vous le dire pourquoi ils
prennent pas contact avec nous parce que
six points des contacts avec nous ils
nous diraient comment vous avez des
problèmes de santé vous avez des petites
maladie le cancer la maladie de
parkinson
alors voilà chaque être humain va
prendre cette pilule et vous ne serez
plus jamais malades et tous ceux qui
sont malades sont instantanément guéri
plus de médecins plus d'hôpitaux plus de
cliniques etc et dise comment vous
envoyez vos enfants à l'école à la
maternelle depuis l'âge de 3 ans jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans pour ceux qui font des
études très supérieure écoutez c'est pas
compliqué chez nous vous essayez dans ce
recueil
vous avez un casque et en trois secondes
vous avez toute la connaissance au plus
près son savoir sur les étapes et rech
merci beaucoup